écoutez sophie pour le moment pas plus
d'information ici place beauvau tous les
journalistes attendent la sortie d'
emmanuel macron et de jean castex
emmanuel macron qui a quitté l'elysée à
pied il y à peu près un peu plus d'une
demi heure pour se rendre place beauvau
juste derrière moi pour cette cellule de
crise entre gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur jean castex
le premier ministre le président de la
république jean castex qui était ce
matin à l'assemblée nationale pour
détailler les mesures de confinement
annoncées par emails macron hier pour
faire face à cette nouvelle vague de
coronavirus des annonces qui ont dû être
interrompu la séance a été interrompue
quand le président de l'assemblée
nationale monsieur ferrand a annoncé
cette attaque denis ceux survenus ce
matin et députés ont respecté une minute
de silence et puis on a pu avoir
quelques réactions notamment celle
d'eric ciotti à la sortie de l'hémicycle
je vous propose l'écouté c'est
naturellement un sentiment de d'immenses
émotions qui mettra un instant je vais
me rendre sur place avec le ministre
dans quelques minutes
nous n'avons pas d'éléments sur le cadre
de cette attaque mais semble-t-il
d'après les informations dont nous
disposons à cette heure de la part des
forces de secours
ça ressemble en tout point à une attaque
terroriste
merci à nos policiers municipaux qui ont
interpellé l'auteur d'une attaque à
l'armé blanche dans le secteur notre
dame à nice je demande aux niçois
d'éviter le secteur
pour laisser la police et des secours
travailler à l'issue de cette réunion de
crise place beauvau emmanuel macron et
jean castex se rendront à nice d'après
l'elysée c'est prévu pour la fin de
matinée à nice où a eu lieu
et cette attaque ce matin de pas après
les premiers éléments de l'enquète trois
personnes sont mortes ce matin deux
hommes et une femme
la première victime a été une femme
égorgée en plein coeur de la halle de
l'église la cathédrale de notre-dame de
l'ascension à nice et puis le deuxième
victime un homme blessé à coups de
couteau
il est mort de ses blessures et une
troisième victime qui a été tuée
toujours à coups de couteau à
l'extérieur de l'édifice alors qu'ils
essayaient de se protéger d'une cellule
antiterroriste a été créé le parquet
antiterroriste a été saisie de cette
affaire pour le moment on n'a pas encore
plus d'informations concernant le profil
de l'assaillant tout ce qu'on peut
savoir c'est qu'il a été blessé par
balle par la police afin de
l'interpeller il a été conduit dans un
état grave à l'hôpital volaient les
informations qu'on a pour le moment
concernant cette attaque survenue ce
matin à nice à notre dame de
l'assomption la cellule de crise est
toujours en cours et bien sûr nous
reviendrons vers vous dès que ces
cellules sera terminée que jean castex
emmanuel macron et quitteront la place
beauvau merci